Hi.
Welcome to the introduction to
the Google Maps API tutorial.
My name is Mano Marks.
I'm a Developer Advocate on
the Google Maps team.
In this tutorial, I will teach
you the basics of using the
Google Maps API in your
web applications.
To fully take advantage of the
content in this presentation,
you should have a basic
understanding of JavaScript
and HTML and access
to a text editor.
In this tutorial, you'll be
constructing a map that has
these basic features--
a basic map, a map marker, which
when clicked, has an
InfoWindow pop-up, an auto
complete form, and current
weather forecasts.
We've set up a site to
walk you through
each of these steps.
Go to this URL for
the tutorial.
OK.
So you see this URL, click
on Your first map.
You'll see there's some
instructions on the left, and
some code on the right.
Click on the HTML tag
on the right, here.
And you'll see that we
have a script tag
with a source attribute.
This script tag loads
the Google Maps
API JavaScript loader.
You'll see that the loader adds
a sensor parameter, which
in turn takes a value
of true or false.
Now one of the most common Maps
API mistakes is to not
set this parameter correctly.
Developers often leave it off
or leave it with the value
true or false, which is one,
big, string value, which is in
some of the documentation.
Unless your application is
getting location information
from your device, say a GPS on
a phone or HTML5 geolocation
from your browser, use false.
Otherwise, use true.
Once it's set, you don't
have to worry about it.
It doesn't impact your
application one way or another.
It's a tracking mechanism
for us.
Next you see that there's
a development
with the idea of map.
This is where our JavaScript
will place the
map, once it's loaded.
OK.
Let's add in a basic map.
Click over to the
JavaScript tab.
It has all the code
that you need.
First create an options
object, in
this case, map options.
You have to select at least
three options--
zoom, center, and
the map type.
Your basic map type options are
roadmap, terrain, or satellite.
Then create a new Google Maps
map object and pass the map
div and the options object.
There, you should have
a map right?
Actually, if you click
Run, you'll see
that nothing happens.
This brings us to the second
most common mistake in Maps
API applications--
failure to properly set
the CSS for your page.
Click on the CSS tab, and remove
the slashes before the
line that says pound map.
Then hit Run again.
You'll see that it now works.
And we have this nice map.
OK.
So now click the Next button
on the tutorial.
All right.
So now let's add a marker
to the map.
Map marker is a familiar
sight on maps.
You've probably seen this red
marker on many websites.
To add a basic marker, add a few
lines of code after you've
created the map.
First, create another options
object, in this
case, marker options.
And add a position option
that uses the Google
Maps LatLong object.
This should create a lat/long
object, which we used in the
first bit of code for the
center of the map.
This is a basic building
block of the Maps API.
Each lat/long object
has a latitude
and longitude property.
Next you create a
marker object.
Finally, add it to the map
by running set map.
And then you click Run.
You should see the map now
has a marker on it.
Let's move on to the
next section.
Here we're going to create a
InfoWindow and attach it to
the marker.
An InfoWindow is an overlay,
like the marker object.
It is used to display
information in
plain text or HTML.
Going to modify your
code a bit here.
Create another options object.
So here you see InfoWindow
options.
And you're giving it a content
property, which you are going
to assign some basic text.
Next create the InfoWindow
object.
Finally, we're going to add an
event listener, which will
cause the InfoWindow to open
when you click on the map.
To do this, just use
Google.maps.event.addlistener,
pass in the objects to be
listened to, in this case, the
marker, the type of event, in
this case, a click, and a
function, which executes when
the event is triggered.
In this case, the InfoWindow
opens on the
marker in the map.
OK.
Now click Run.
You should see a map that
looks like this.
And when you click on the
marker, the InfoWindow opens.
Click on the Next button to
move to the next section.
Now we're going to add in
AutoComplete to your map.
AutoComplete is part of the
Places Library of the Google
Maps API, which lets you take
advantage of Google's data
store of tens of millions of
places around the world.
A place is anything from an
address to a landmark, a
restaurant, a place
of worship, or
a government building.
We have, in fact, over
125 different
categories of places.
AutoComplete lets you put one
input box on your page, and
users can type in
their requests.
In real time, as they are
typing, Google will then try
to match their requests.
Let's take a look at the code.
First thing we'd need to
change is the HTML.
We need to add in an input
element with type text and an
ID, in this case,
AutoComplete.
Click on the HTML
tab to see this.
Notice, too, that we added in
a libraries parameter to the
JavaScript loader.
This one is libraries
equals places.
Google Maps API libraries are
integrated libraries with the
Maps API code, but they are
loaded separately and only
when needed.
OK.
Click on back over to
the JavaScript tab.
You're going to create
an options object.
In this case, we're just going
to limit the type of responses
to establishments.
So here we have AC options.
And then you see types,
establishments.
Establishments are not
geocodeable addresses, but
they're basically places
of business.
So cafes, restaurants, whatever,
shopping malls.
Next you create the AutoComplete
object itself.
And pass in the AutoComplete
elements.
And then we bind that
AutoComplete
object to the map.
That means it will just show
results that are within the
current bounds of the map.
Finally, we're going to create a
listener, an event listener,
on the AutoComplete object.
And this basically
just listens for
changes in the selection.
It then places a marker on the
map and opens an InfoWindow
with the name of the place.
All right.
So now click Run.
And you'll see here that there
is a map, and as I type in SF,
you'll see San Francisco-related
places
showing up.
So I'm going to click one.
And clicking in SFO, which is
the airport, and you'll see it
opens up, a pop-up
with the name.
All right.
Let's click over to
the next section.
And lastly, we're going to add
a weather layer to your
application.
There's a number of different
layer types available to you
in the Google Maps API,
including Panoramio, KML
layers, traffic, bicycling,
and more.
Most of them take only a few
lines of code to add to a map.
So first off, we just create the
weather layer object and
pass it a new options object.
In this case, we're setting the
temperature unit type to
Fahrenheit.
This is North America, but
you can also do Celsius.
Then we are going to set the
weather layer to the map,
weatherlayer.setmap.
Then we are going to finally
create a cloud layer and set
that on the map.
You click Run, and you'll see
that you have basic weather
showing up.
And if I clicked on one, I'll
get a forecast for that
particular point.
You don't see any clouds,
because currently it's not
cloudy in San Francisco.
So I'm going to just zoom out,
and then you see there are
actually clouds there.
So this weather layer produces
weather that is--
forecasts that are available up
to 15 minutes ago, and then
clouds that are within
the last three hours.
So now you have up and running
basic Google Maps API
applications.
And you're good to go.
If you want any more information
on the Google Maps
API, check out the
documentation on
developers.google.com/maps.
Thank you very much.